bonsoir le 7,8 à l'acte chaque soir de
la semaine en direct à 18h bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle édition voici les
principales informations dans les idées
dans ce 26 septembre une visite
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui celle du
campus scientifique de l'entreprise
colas leader mondial de la construction
des routes le campus est installé à
magny les hameaux et puis un conseil
municipal ce soir à maurepas qui signe
le retour du maire georges dojo absent
depuis plusieurs semaines un conseil sur
fond de tension trois maires adjoints
souhaite se présenter aux prochaines
municipales
la rentrée scolaire est passé pourtant
certains lycéens n'ont pas d'affectation
ou veulent changer d'orientation le
dispositif sos rentrée est là pour les
vidéos reportages en quelques instants à
versailles allez on commence le journal
de ce soir par quelques images alors
elles sont signées ce soir à jacques
patrick jacques de dixmude c'était il y
à quelques instants en fin d'après midi
à versailles l'inauguration de la
bibliothèque ce franco allemand de quoi
s'agit-il et bien transformer des
cabines téléphoniques voilà on va
découvre la cabine téléphonique devenu
obsolète en bois talibans c'est très
joli en tout cas très coloré où l'on
échange des ouvrages le projet est
écologique car cette éclairé grâce à des
panneaux photovoltaïques
c'est un projet qui est né de la
coopération de la maison de l'europe et
d'un institut a basé à berlin voilà donc
un symbole de l'amitié franco allemande
et cela ne pouvait que réjouir constant
que constance le grip députée européenne
présente à lors de cette inauguration
l'écoutent c'est effectivement une
illustration concrète est tout à fait
sympathique positive
de la coopération franco allemand de
l'amitié franco allemande
et en cette année de célébration du 50e
anniversaire du traité de l'elysée
participer sur le terrain concrètement
dans les départements franciliens
à l'affichage
d'opérations de ces gens me semblait
être tout à fait intéressant pour un
député européen voilà pour
l'inauguration de cette bibliobus
c'était il ya quelques instants à
versailles colas leader mondial dans la
construction des routes a tout
simplement son campus scientifique vous
ne le savez peut-être pas implanté à
manille et les hameaux et cela depuis
plus de vingt ans alors c'est un
laboratoire d'où sortent toutes les
dernières innovations de la
multinationale car cambier elodie moines
ont visité les locaux
le campus scientifique et technique de
colas le cst est le premier centre
mondial de recherche et développement
privées dédiées à la route il est
installé à magny les hameaux et ce jeudi
il ouvrait ses portes c'est une première
parce qu'on a conduit depuis deux ans
des travaux de restructuration sur le
site des travaux de développement de
certains outils on arrive à
l'aboutissement de l'ensemble de ces
travaux il semblait légitime de faire
connaître aux collaborateurs du groupe
d'une part mais également à nos clients
les nouveaux outils dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui sur le site du de magny les
hameaux
l'entreprise colas spécialisée dans la
construction et l'entretien des routes
s'attachent à trouver de nouvelles
techniques ou d'un nouveau matériau pour
augmenter la performance ou encore
l'empreinte écologique dans ce
laboratoire
flavien test l'adhérence des chaussées
cette machine permet de vieillir les
échantillons ces recherches ont permis
de créer un en vendée plus performant le
petit grippe on va être sur des taux aux
accidents tout jeunes qui sont divisés
par 10
avec des produits très sécuritaire ici
on a trouvé le moyen d'augmenter la
rétro réflexion des revêtements au sol
la bande c est est plus visible son
secret elle est sous poudre et de billes
de verre qui réfléchissent la lumière
autres thèmes de recherche l'étude de
l'usure des routes ce prototype permet
de retranscrire l'état de la route et
les fissures éventuelle grâce à des
lasers projetés sur le sol
la vitesse d'acquisition est de 80 km
heure pour une résolution des images de
1 mm donc ça nous permet d'avoir un très
très haut rendement au point de vue
auscultation des chaussées après
traitement des images on peut anticiper
les travaux de rénovation à moyen terme
dans cet autre laboratoire sébastien
cherche à limiter le bruit de roulement
et donc les nuisances sonores il cherche
le meilleur matériau pour améliorer le
coefficient d'absorption acoustique il
faut réfléchissantes pour le bonifier on
a différents hôtes ils ces autistes là
pour optimiser notre formule et si vous
voulez c'est comme une recette de
cuisine on va jouer avec nos ingrédients
jouer sur les différentes proportions on
va aussi par exemple jouer sur la taille
des granulats son diamètre
étonnamment entre ces deux enrobé c'est
celui de droite qui limite le plus le
bruit huit fois moins qu'un euro mais
classique la société colas présente sur
les cinq continents se charge de 100
mille chantiers dans le monde son
chiffre d'affaires s'élève à 13
milliards d'euros
on va passer aux routes maintenant aux
pistes cyclables ferme du manège
continue jusqu'à vendredi on ne parle
que de vélo à l'occasion des dix
septième rencontre régions et
départements cyclable alors l'occasion
pour nous de faire le point sur les
infrastructures existantes les yvelines
par exemple propose 850 km d'itinéraires
cyclables et ce n'est pas fini
pendant deux jours à la ferme du manet
de montigny ont par le vélo et rien que
vélo à l'occasion des dix septième
rencontre des départements et régions
cyclables environ soixante douze
collectivités conviées il faut sans
cesse motivé car cela coûte toutefois
assez cher entre cent mille et un
million d'euros du kilomètre réalisée et
il est nécessaire de rappeler aussi la
loi car en la matière il ya des devoirs
la loi lors dite loi sur l'air du 1er
janvier 1997 qui oblige les
collectivités quand un tel fonds des
aménagements routiers
dans la commune donc à l'agglomération
de créer en même temps d'aménagements
cyclables pour mettre les cyclistes en
sécurité la plupart ne le font pas
malgré tout lors de cette 17e rencontre
une note positive il ya des
améliorations des yvelines par exemple
compte 850 km d'itinéraires cyclables un
budget de 4 millions par an
subventionner les projets des communes
on a lancé la politique cyclable
organisée très volontariste depuis six
ans on s'est doté d'une d'instruments ce
qui vont à la fois de la sensibilisation
dans les collèges et cetera jusqu'à la
réalisation d'infrastructures
le but constituer un réseau de pistes
continuent le projet a été lancé il ya
trois ans via un schéma départemental et
devrait aboutir d'ici une dizaine
d'années à créer une boucle de 550 km un
enjeu pour leur environnement certes
mais un enjeu aussi pour l'économie via
l'apport de touristes la loire à vélo
300 km les châteaux mais c'est énorme
l'amortissement de la véloroute a été
fait a été fait en six mois la france
est la deuxième destination pour le
tourisme à vélo en europe après
l'allemagne
voilà et puis sachez également que des
labels vélo pour les hôtels vont faire
leur apparition un peu partout en france
et notamment dans les yvelines pour
bénéficier de ces labels tous les hôtels
devront disposer d'un espace sécurisé
pour angers les deux roues et pouvoir
également proposer des espaces buanderie
réservés aux cyclistes cantine entre
mouy et de balades le conseil municipal
de maurepas va se tenir ce jeudi soir et
tignes tout d'abord le retour aux
affaires du maire divers gauche georges
mougeot absent depuis plusieurs mois
pour des motifs de santé mais il sera
aussi regardée de près pour ces tensions
en vue des élections municipales dans
les rangs de la majorité trois adjoints
rien que rien que cela pardon ont déjà
émis le souhait de se présenter
pierre leguérinel premier adjoint
délégué aux grands projets de lille
michel chapa adjoint aux finances et
hervé miclo adjoint à la culture rappel
des faits avec will fait de réchy
jeudi 26 septembre 20h45 s'ouvrira le
conseil municipal de maurepas un conseil
anodin en apparence et pourtant il sera
marqué par le retour aux affaires du
maire divers gauche georges mougeot en
retrait depuis plusieurs mois en raison
de problèmes de santé il avait cédé sa
place à son premier adjoint lui dit
pierre le goring dans l'opposition
également du changement puisque l'ump
grégory gars restiez siègera pour la
première fois il viendra pallier au
départ d'un autre élu démissionnaire des
allées et venues qui s'opèrent sur fond
de tension en vue des prochaines
élections municipales
s'il refuse pour l'instant toute
interview le maire sortant ne serait pas
candidat en mars prochain michel chappe
à son adjoint aux finances revendique
d'ailleurs son soutien et annonce sa
candidature
dans le même temps pierre leguérinel le
premier adjoint centriste va lui aussi
se présenter sans le soutien du maire
dont qui peut être sans le soutien de
l'ump qu'il espère pourtant un autre
brigue l'investiture de l'ump grégory
gary astier responsable de la section
locale du parti de droite et pour
ajouter à la confusion un autre adjoint
au maire louis socialiste hervé miclo
brigue l'appui du ps dans cette campagne
qui s'annonce mais il retrouve sur sa
route le conseiller général de gauche
ismaila val saint-côme dont trois
adjoints de l'actuelle majorité pour un
seul poste de maire et rien ne dit que
la situation puisse se débloquer dans
les prochaines semaines
voilà et puis toujours en politique ces
mères qui disent non aux rythmes
scolaires une pétition circule en ce
moment à l'initiative du maire
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous ce
dernier juge la réforme coûteuse
juste et elle aurait selon lui pour
effet de fatigue et les enfants jean
michel fourgous demande au ministre de
l'éducation nationale vincent peillon de
remettre à plat cette réforme est
d'autoriser les communes a reporté son
application qui doit avoir lieu à la
rentrée à 2014 dans les yvelines huit
communes sont déjà passés à la réforme
des quatre jours et demi dont trappe sur
notre secteur et puis toujours en
politique 50 députés ump ont demandé ce
mercredi la création ce jeudi pardon la
création d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire sur distille les dérives
communautaristes après les événements de
trappes survenu en juillet dernier parmi
les signataires de droite le
bouillonnant député de maisons laffitte
jacques mia mais également le député de
la 12e circonscription david douillet ou
encore jean frédéric poisson également
député des yvelines selon les
signataires de la proposition ces
évènements traduisent la volonté des
intégristes islamistes d'installer
d'imposer leur loi voilà sur cette
enquête parlementaire on passe
maintenant l'entretien de ce soir qui
n'a rien à voir avec votre nom de la
panouse bonsoir vous êtes en plateau
avec nous parce que la tva qui concerne
le parc de thoiry va passer de 7% elle
est actuellement 7% à 10% d'ici le mois
de janvier 2014 alors on se dit que
trois points de plus de tva c'est pas
bien grand chose et pourtant vous vous
êtes en colère puisque vous voulez
d'adresser lettre au ministre
expliquez-nous pourquoi alors déjà pour
appeler un peu le contexte en mon père
en tant que présidents d'associations de
tous les parcs zoologiques français
avait obtenu à l'époque un taux de ré
réduit de tva à 5 5% pour parce que nous
nous sommes un élevage l école classée
comme un gavage agricole à vocation
scientifique et pédagogique
c'est vous que cette émission là ont été
confirmés en 2004 par un arrêté
ministériel ça c'était de 72 à 2011
cossette jusqu'à 2 millions donc jusqu'à
2011 on allait au taux de tva à 5,5 est
donc on avait on a 7 me en à ses
missions par un matin un arrêté
ministériel de 2004 confirme ça que nous
devons être pédagogie scientifiques ils
vont se voir les écoles nous devons
avoir des problèmes pédagogiques nous
devons élever les animaux dans des
bonnes conditions dans le cadre de
programmes de reproduction européen il
ya tout un ensemble
environnementale et
pédagogique qui nous incombent dans nos
milliers dans nos missions et dans notre
quotidien les notes travail il se trouve
qu'en 2011 il ya une augmentation des
émissions à 7% qui s'est appliqué parce
que c'est au général il s'appuyait tout
le monde donc comme s'applique à tout le
monde en objet de ce faux pas on va
parler de céder un peu pas résisté par
contre là on veut nous faire une
augmentation qui est spécifique qui
passerait de 7 à 10 parce qu'on estime
que vous êtes aujourd'hui assigné un
parc de loisirs alors on nous confond
année par l'attraction qui font de leur
côté leur travail qui ont eu un taux
réduit pendant longtemps mais ça c'est
par rapport au fait que disney est
arrivé quand disney est arrivé dans un
80 il avait négocié le taux réduit à 5,5
aussi c'était un peu inspiré notre
démarche mais pas pour les mêmes raisons
le problème c'est que on s'est rendu
compte que il y en a qui ont déjà
bénéficié d'un taux réduit
à 5,5 aujourd'hui sont revenus un taux
réduit à 5,5 et notamment les cirques
les cinémas aussi un certain nombre de
choses je pas bonne et une polémique et
par rapport avec eux ils font leur le
meeting il faut ils ont leur mission ils
ont leurs fonctions mais je considère
que c'est un peu étonnant que nous les
parizeau logique particulière parler du
privé
soyons vous soyez à se banaliser tivité
6000 et déjà une activité qui est pas la
nôtre alors qu'on a notre vie on nous
sommes des éleveurs de faune sauvage
avec et des scientifiques qui ouvriront
au public et c'est le public nous parler
par privé c'est la grâce aux billets
d'entrée que les on peut remplir ses
missions on ne reçoit pas de subvention
pour ses missions
donc c'est le sait le bus et visiteurs
c'est grâce aux visiteurs qu'on peut
assumer entièrement ses missions donc le
fait d'augmenter le taux de tva à 7 déjà
ça a causé un premier sacre après ceux
que j'aime bien ça coûtait 150 mille
euros inc c'était pour les dernières 5 5
dans deux on a perdu 150 millions euros
par an et les premiers coups ont été
pénalisés en histoire c'est d'abord
l'état sur l'impôt sur les bénéfices
parce qu' on a eu moins suivi de
l'intéressement la participation pour
les salariés aussi et ensuite les
animaux parce que ça nous a fait on a eu
moins d'argent pour investir dans les
nouveaux bassins de natation animalière
quand on prend un point à un point et
demi de tva on perd 150 mille saveurs
comprenait trois points avait par trois
cent mille exactement donc là ça ne va
nous faire en ça va nous faire cent
cinquante mille occasions fois de donc
ça veut 300 + 300 familles vont s'y sont
mis donc vous avez écrit une lettre
assez longue mais que toi amusante
d'ailleurs au mini et des finances n'a
fait une lettre ouverte en disant que si
vous deviez pas si vous aussi vous
deviez est assignée par exemple au cir
pour revenir à une tva réduite vous
seriez prêt à mettre le nez rouge c'est
mon père connaissez vous plaît à vous
faire
il a la possibilité en tant que
fondateur à la retraite de faire ce
qu'il veut donner oui lui il s'est
engagé à mettre le nez rouge et saluent
alors assez votre père aussi peut-être
qu'à proposer aussi aux mines et de
l'économie de venir sur place alors
c'est nous tous se rencontrer les
girafes est-ce que du coup sans
plaisanter mais du coup après cette
lettre que vous avez envoyé au ministre
est-ce que vous avez mais un retour est
ce que ministre à vie on est alors à
venir voir sur place que votre activité
n'est pas un césar ce qui est à césar
l'administration prend encore un peu de
temps pour répondre
et
les courriers sont partis entre la
semaine dernière et cette semaine pour
justement que les élus notamment
spécialement les parlementaires et tous
les queues et tous ses cours et chacun
un courrier au moment où ils le croisent
le premier ministre est à dire hier et
aujourd'hui c'est ont respectivement au
sénat à l'assemblée
donc on attend les réponses mais
j'espère qu'on aura surtout un soutien
de tous les de tous les élus de tous
bords parce que moi nous avons quatre
parcs en france ne sait pas que le parc
de thoiry donc une travaillons et des
élus de tous bords et qui sont très
impliqués dans l'aménagement de leur
territoire nous soutenons leur couleur
politique des territoires par nos le
fait d'être présents et de créer une
activité
est il pour nous il est important que de
se sentir un peu soutenu quand on se
retrouve dans un traitement fiscal qui
est extrêmement discriminatoire et c'est
un peu la double peine parce que on
est les bons élèves et on nous punit et
on s'énerve parce que pour rappeler vous
faites des actions pédagogiques parce
qu'on a des actions environnementales
faut pas oublier nos animaux on n'achète
pas nos animaux nous animaux sont
confiés par des programmes européens sur
avec des critères très très stricte qui
demandent des très gros investissement
on peut pas en parler facilement de
500000 à 4,5 millions d'euros pour une
présentation animalière le simple
transporte cette fête de transporter des
bonnes conditions
un éléphant par exemple ses 15000 euros
le transport parce que c'est il ya que
deux transporteurs algré dans toute
l'europe qui font ça très bien pour les
animaux arrivent en bonne santé c'est
toute une procédure on n'est pas dans on
n'est pas dans une situation
on n'est pas dans des situations on peut
faire que les choses comme on veut
heureusement d'ailleurs nous sommes des
professionnels des scientifiques et nous
voulons faire les choses vraiment
correctement mais pourquoi aller frapper
les bons élèves
pour quelque chose qui in fine et ne
rapportera que peut-être deux trois
quatre peut-être 5 millions la meilleure
année pour pour l'état vous avez parlé
des conséquences pour les finances du
parc de thoiry est-ce qu'elle a aussi
des conséquences pour les personnes les
visiteurs qui vont venir au point
qu'aujourd'hui vous de voir répercuter
s'assure la hausse alors on se dit
blessé pour eux cette part embêtant mais
assez simple augmentation la double
augmentation en deux ans va faire que le
prix d'entrée est augmentée de 1 euro 1
euro qui ira entièrement et caisses de
l'état je le rappelle et 7 euros nous on
va en impact et une partie sur les
visiteurs parce que on peut pas assumer
l'âge de cette charge nous mêmes parce
que ça pénalise l'entreprise et le
développement de l'entreprise donc il ya
une pareille une partie va être pris en
charge pour les visiteurs et puis notre
parti bah ça va être en perte et profite
pour nous ça va être autant temps de
présentation et des manières en moins
aux repoussé dans le temps et si
l'intéressement en moins pour les
salariés alors socialement c'est pas
idéal surtout qu'au moment où vous
relancer la consommation en augmentant
les revenus des ménages et par les
salariés justement ce qu'il ya aussi
d'autres d'autres impacts des choses que
vous auriez pu mettre en place si la tva
était évident que vous pourriez
peut-être pas mettre en place baboo les
salariés ont fait faut savoir que je
suis aussi que fera qu'on fasse beaucoup
mais qu'on fait ce qu'on une entreprise
responsable et censée faire on paye des
frais kilométriques pour les transports
sachant que le logement dans les
yvelines c'est pas facile donc les
formes des salariés certains vont dans
les départements voisins pour se loger
on a construit des logements sociaux ce
et il nous a fallu se battre très dur
très durement qu'on pourra les obtenir
pour qu'ils puissent se loger à pas cher
parce que toujours ses touches alors les
yvelines la mutuelle est prise à 100%
par les entreprises qui est une bonne
chose je considère qu'il est important
que les salariés qui travaillent
certains sont nés sont dans les bureaux
sapins sont sur le terrain je fais pas
de différence entre à être toujours mais
pour moi tout le monde doit être bien
couvert et surtout qu on a différents
corps de métier et pas que les
animaliers qui sont dehors qui
différents corps de métiers qui ont fait
un travail parfois dans les conditions
que c'est pas facile puisque l'on
travaille dehors dans les conditions
climatiques sont pas toujours évident il
est important que tout le monde soit en
bonne santé bonfoh salariés l'entreprise
à peu près au groupe avec les
saisonniers autour de 81 4
derniers mots vous avez je présume
envoyer aussi la lettre au député de la
circonscription
alors nous avons voyez nous avons envoyé
à lens bien sûr un autre député et qui
nous représente et mais aussi à tous les
députés et les députés certains étant
des suppléants d'autres élus qui sont
pas tant des fonctions importantes et je
pense que
je pense notamment monsieur benoît hamon
qui m'unissent de la consommation je
sais qu'il est concerné par ce sujet
parce que partie son sujet j'ai ne sais
pas et je ne critique surtout pas son
action sur le sujet je pense que il il
comprend très bien le problème et après
à charge dans cette énorme histoire
c'est que les choses les choses avec les
choses que les choses se discute j'ai
pas une résonance directe je ne fais que
spéculer pour l'instant je fais
qu'espéré je dirais et bah écoute un bon
résultat on peut vous souhaiter de ce
retour à une tva à 5,5 à taux réduit
pour le parc de vol pour les phares
zoologie pour les parcs zoologiques
parce que il ya deux parts qui sont eux
très menacée qui risquent de fermer
merci à vous expliquer cette
problématique en plateau vous êtes
lycéen et peut être que vous n'avez pas
encore d'affectation pour cette
prochaine rentrée scolaire un dispositif
sos rentrée là pour vous aider
direction yvelines information jeunesse
pour savoir concrètement comment cela
fonctionne olivet maniscalco et patrick
jacq de dix semaines dans l'informatique
youssef a 20 ans et vient de rater son
bac pour la seconde fois lassé du
système scolaire il cherche désormais
une formation professionnalisante pour
se relancer en quête de solutions il
s'est donc rendu ce mercredi après midi
au bureau d'yves une information
jeunesse à versailles pour l'opération
sos rentrée sur place de nombreux
intervenants accueille les jeunes centre
d'information et d'orientation
professionnelle recrutement des armées
ou écoles de la deuxième chance le choix
est large l'occasion pour youssef de
rencontrer des professionnels ou des
conseillers pour définir au mieux sa
future orientation ce matin je suis
parti à une école informatique qu'on
m'avait recommandé à paris et là tout
était complet donc je suis en attente de
formation et je suis venu aujourd'hui
puisque à la porte ouverte donc je
m'attendais à ce qui est des réponses à
mes questions je les ai eus nous l'idée
en tant que généraliste de l'information
c'est d'inviter les référents sur les
partenaires des yvelines et de proposer
le maximum de possibilités selon les
profils des jeunes on accueille au
préalable jeunes donc ici à l'extérieur
on va essayer décrypter avec lui sa
demande ses besoins et en fonction de
cela on va le diriger vers le ou les
partenaires qui vont pouvoir répondre à
ces questions et approfondir avec lui
sur ces thématiques l'art
une fois le contact établi ce sont les
organismes sollicités qui assureront un
suivi avec ces jeunes dossier
d'inscription pour une formation cv ou
lettre de motivation pour un employeur
la prise en charge continuera jusqu'à ce
qu'une solution soit trouvée
de l'enseignement il s'appelle boulevard
des airs et sont nommés pour les
victoires de la musique et sont en
concert en ce moment même à l'occasion
du festival de la vie étudiante balance
la sauce qui se tient ce jeudi à
guyancourt reportage
les joues au foot avant leur concert le
groupe boulevard désert récompensé aux
victoires de la musique 2013 est
l'invité d'honneur du festival balance
la sauce ce jeudi à l'université de
versailles saint quentin et
d'association en fait on fait appel à
nous pour pour finir toutes leurs
journées de sensibilisation aux
associations voilà pour finir par un
concert et ils ont pensé à vouloir des
airs et nous ont accepté l'invitation
avec plaisir on les a connus selon
l'étude puisque on est on est tous
passés par les universités vont nous
c'était à toulouse donc ces quelques
kilowatts d'ici mais on a déjà participé
moi j'ai déjà vu des concerts à toulouse
et je trouve ça très bien qu'ils fassent
ce qu'ils fassent ça ici donc on est
très contents d'être là pour clôturer à
ste première journée les associations et
la direction de la vie étudiante
présente pour la sixième édition aux
nouveaux inscrits ou aux anciens
l'étendue des activités proposées au
sein de l'université les objectifs de
cette journée étudiante et de favoriser
les premiers contacts les nouveaux
arrivants en étudiant et les
associations qui sont déjà en place à
l'université c'est aussi quand il fait
beau une journée ludique donc on essaye
de de faire vivre et animer le campus
une vingtaine d'associations intervient
tout au long de l'année et facilite la
vie étudiante dans les domaines de la
culture de l'environnement ou encore de
l'aide aux démarches administratives
nous avons aujourd'hui il a cité un
certain nombre d'associations étudiantes
celles ci sont dynamiques et par cette
journée elle tente de recruter des
nouveaux adhérents pour pouvoir faire
de nouvelles choses chaque année c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui la tendance actuelle
c'est
c'est plutôt une logique d'individus
individualisme maintenant on commence à
avoir des étudiants dès la première
année s'intéresser au tissu associatif
est finalement valoriser ses engagements
au terme de leur cursus
de nombreuses animations ponctuent le
festival tout au long de la journée
tournoi sportif buvette ateliers et bien
entendu le concert ouvert à tous de
boulevard des airs
c'est pas mal desigual et pour terminer
cette édition notre question du jour que
pensez vous de la vie associative à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
réponse des étudiants très présente
justement c'est ça que ça que je trouve
très bien c'est vrai qu'on nous a tout
de suite mis dans le bain et on est très
encadrée par cette vie étudiant qui est
vraiment très sympathique ça bouge pas
trop ça bouge pas trop je trouve à part
aujourd'hui il faut une tournée de
présentation mais en général ça sent pas
très active dans les autres facs on sait
que holly oh ils sont toujours animés
ici c'est plutôt une fois par an ou
poser des événements préparer la vie
estudiantine est très importante et du
milieu associatif aussi le mois
actuellement du bda forcerie nous nous
engageons à faire ça et franchement je
vois que d'autres associations le font
et feront participer les étudiants à
plusieurs activités je trouve ça
vraiment très très beau et très utile je
pense que pour une si petite université
ya pas mal d'associations il ya pas mal
de vie étudiante et c'est en train de se
développer en plus en ce moment avec
plein de nouvelles associations qui
arrive donc je trouve ça très bien pour
les étudiants et des journées comme
celle-ci je sais que ça se battent
partout dans toutes les universités dont
je trouve ça très bien et puis toujours
dans le cadre de la vie associative des
étudiants cet autre information qui
concerne cette fois le festival culturel
2013 art in the city qui se tiendra du 3
au 18 octobre sur les différents sites
de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin voilà de quoi
occuper les étudiants allaient faire de
cette édition de journal du 26 septembre
rendez vous demain 18h pour une nouvelle
vision du 7-8 l'actuel n'oubliez pas
nous suivre également sur les réseaux
sociaux bonne soirée et à bientôt